hello and welcome to the 77th annual
Golden Globe Awards live from the
Beverly Hilton Hotel here in Los Angeles
I'm Ricky Gervais is thank you you're
you'll be pleased to know this is the
last time I'm hosting these awards so I
don't care anymore
um I'm joking I never did MBC clearly
don't care either fifth time so I mean
Kevin Hart was fired from the Oscars
because of some offensive tweets hello
lucky for me the Hollywood Foreign Press
can barely speak English
and they have no idea what Twitter is so
I got offered this gig by fax so let's
go out with a bang let's have a laugh at
your expense
shall we remember they're just jokes
we're all gonna die soon and there's no
sequel so yeah remember that but you all
look lovely all dolled up you came here
in your limos I came here in a limo
tonight and the license plate was made
by Felicity Huffman so no sure it's a
it's her daughter I feel sorry for okay
that must be the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to her and her dad
was in wild hogs so
lots of big celebrities here tonight I
mean legends icons yeah that this table
alone
Al Pacino Robert DeNiro
baby Yoda oh I guess that's Joe Pesci's
sorry um I Love You Man don't have me
whacked
um but tonight isn't just about the
people in front of camera in this room
are some of the most important TV and
film executives in the world people from
every background but they all have one
thing in common they're all terrified of
Ronan Farrow he's coming for you he's
coming for you look talking of all you
perverts it was a big year it was a big
year for pedophile movies surviving
r.kelly
leaving Neverland two popes
I don't care I don't care many talented
people of color was snubbed in major
categories unfortunately there's nothing
we can do about that the Hollywood
Foreign Press are all very very racist
so fifth time so we were gonna do an in
memoriam this year but when I saw the
list of people that had died it wasn't
diverse enough they just no it was
mostly white people and I thought now
not on my watch
maybe next year let's let's see what
happens no one cares about movies
anymore no one goes to cinema no one
really what his network TV
everyone's watching Netflix this show
should just be me coming out going well
done Netflix you win everything good
night but no no we got to drag out for
three hours you could binge watch the
entire first season of afterlife instead
of watching this show that that's a show
about a man who wants to kill himself
because his wife dies of cancer and it's
still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way
so in the end he obviously didn't kill
himself just like Jeffrey Epstein shut
up
I know he's your friend but I don't care
you had to make your own way here in
your own plane didn't ya right but
seriously most films are awful lazy
remakes sequels I've heard a rumor but
there might be a sequel to Sophie's
Choice I mean that had just been Meryl
Streep going what it's gotta be this one
all the best actors have jumped to
Netflix and HBO you know and the actors
who just do Hollywood movies now do
fantasy adventure nonsense they wear
mast and capes and really tight costumes
their job isn't acting anymore
it's going to the gym twice a day and
taking steroids really oh we got a we
got an award for most rip junkie no no
point we know he'd win that um Martin
Scorsese the greatest living director
made the news for his controversial
comments about the Marvel franchise he
said they're not real cinema and they
remind him of theme parks I agree
although I don't know what he's doing
hanging around theme parks he's not big
enough to go on the rides
tiny
right the Irishman was amazing
it was amazing um that was my faith my
fear was great long but amazing
it wasn't the only epic movie once upon
a time in Hollywood nearly three hours
long Leonardo DiCaprio attended the
premiere and by the end his date was too
old for him
even Prince Andrews like come on leo
mate you know you're nearly 50 son the
world got to see James Corden as a fat
[ __ ] it was also in the movie cats but
no one saw that and the reviews are
shocking I saw one that said this is the
worst thing to happen to cats since dogs
right
but Dame Judi Dench defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play because she I can't do this next
day because she loves nothing better
than plunking herself down on the carpet
lifting her leg and licking her
furball furball
she's old school
it's the last time okay
Oh Apple roared into the TV game with a
morning show a superb drama yeah
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity and doing the right thing made
by a company that runs sweatshops in
China so will you say you woke but the
companies you work for I mean
unbelievable Apple Amazon Disney if Isis
started a streaming service you'd call
your agent wouldn't you so if you do win
an award tonight but don't use it as a
platform to make a political speech
right you're in no position to lecture
the public about anything you know
nothing about the real world most of you
spent less time in school than Greta
Thumb Berg so if you win right come up
except you little award thank your agent
and your God
it's already three hours long right
let's do the first award the first award
the first award is for Best Actor in a
television series Musical or Comedy to
present the award are a couple of actors
off the telly what can I say
Jennifer Aniston and Reese Witherspoon